voyez M. Trudeau, il a eu des
rassemblements depuis le début.
Olivier Vachon s'est posé la
question.
- Les bains de foule,
c'est une tradition
des campagnes électorales.
Malgré la pandémie, on a pu voir
les chefs aller à la rencontre
des électeurs.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef,
Parti libéral du Canada
- Ça a été extrêmement agréable
de pouvoir voir les gens.
Évidemment, il faut suivre
les directives de santé
publique.
- Mais est-ce que les chefs
respectent vraiment
toutes les directives?
La réponse est non.
Pour les personnes qui sont
pleinement vaccinées, la santé
publique fédérale indique
que la distanciation physique
et le port du masque
ne sont pas obligatoires lors
des rassemblements en plein air.
Par contre, elle dit qu'il faut
suivre les directives mises
en place par les autorités
locales.
Au Québec, la santé publique
demande aux gens qui n'habitent
pas dans un même foyer
de conserver une distance
d'un mètre, tant à l'intérieur
qu'à l'extérieur.
Justin Trudeau et Jagmeet Singh
ont donc contrevenu à cette
règle lors de leur passage
dans la province, mais au moins,
ils portent le masque,
ce qui est recommandé quand
la distanciation est impossible.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef,
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- On fait tout ce qu'on peut,
on a des protocoles,
comme vous avez vu que je porte
mon masque tout le temps
quand je suis dehors.
(applaudissements)
- Justin Trudeau a, quant à lui,
été pris en défaut une deuxième
fois en participant hier
à un rassemblement extérieur
en Ontario, où la limite de
100 personnes a été dépassée.
- Deux choix s'offrent à vous...
- Depuis le début de la
campagne, le chef conservateur,
Erin O'Toole, s'est largement
tenu à l'écart du public.
Le chef du Bloc québécois,
Yves-François Blanchet, lui,
tente de garder ses distances
avec les électeurs quand
il participe à des événements
extérieurs.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chef, Bloc québécois
- Moi, je ne donne pas le coude,
j'embrasse pas, je ne donne pas
la main, je ne fais pas
le petit poing, on va éviter
les "high five".
- Si les chefs, pleinement
vaccinés et masqués, ont peu de
chances de contracter la COVID,
les experts s'inquiètent
davantage pour les gens
non vaccinés qui pourraient
se retrouver dans
leurs rassemblem